more things you need to know about
lab-grown meat number one growing meat
in a lab is finally possible and
becoming more practical everyday the
process pioneered by researcher mark
post from Maastricht University starts
like this
scientists harmlessly extract stem cells
called myocyte alight cells from a small
sample of muscle tissue from the source
animal in this case a cow the scientist
coax them to differentiate into muscle
cells which then naturally form small
fibers called Myo tubes when placed
around a circular hub made of gel the
Myo tubes start bulking up growing
larger and combining to form a small
piece of muscle tissue mcLeese pieces of
muscle tissue along with cultured fat
tissue and you get something that looks
and tastes like meat number two
according to an Oxford University study
this cultured meat could be produced
with up to 96 percent fewer greenhouse
gas emissions than regular meat and
that's important because livestock
production is the key driver of climate
change the meat industry currently
contributes 44 percent of the world's
methane and 53 percent of the world's of
nitrous oxide emissions in fact
livestock is estimated to account for
more greenhouse gases than the world's
cars trucks boats and planes combined
number three current livestock
production is also incredibly water
intensive but cultured meat is estimated
to require 82 to 96 percent less water
depending on the animal that's a lot of
savings in a world where scarcity is
already causing water to be referred to
as the new oil number four
while the first cultured burger grown by
mark post in 2013 cost three hundred
thirty thousand dollars for just one
patty he expects his group to be able to
produce patties on a large enough scale
to sell them for less than ten dollars
each
by 2020 as posts told The Washington
Post once we can grow the tissue in a
reactor the size of an Olympic swimming
pool we should be able to achieve that
sort of volume